We also have
discount by the way,
my partners and I decided to,
mmm.
Encourage everybody to
make a,
their new year's resolutions in a sophisticated and comprehensive way.
And so we have this program.
Some of you have heard about this@selfauthoring.com called future authoring.
And the future authoring program helps you write out a vision for the future to
think through what you'd like your life to be like if you were taking care of
yourself properly,
to consider your friends and your family and your career and your education and
your use of time outside of work and your ability to resist temptation,
the kind of temptation that might drag you down and,
uh,
and how you might take care of yourself mentally and physically.
And to write about that and then to write a counter,
uh,
story,
which was where you might be three to five years down the road if you let all
your bad habits get out of control and then to write a strategic plan.
It's a very useful program.
We've used it with lots of university students in particular,
although it's for,
for adults of all ages.
Um,
and if you're a university student and you complete the program,
it seems to increase the probability that you'll stay in university by about 25%
something like that.
Um,
it seems particularly useful by the way,
for men,
for reasons that we don't exactly understand,
maybe because they're underperforming women academically and it also improves
people's grades.
But there's a large literature in the industrial organizational area also
indicating that if you're like,
if you're working and you make a personal plan of this sort,
then your overall productivity increases by about 10% which is a lot.
And you're,
you're more likely to be physically and mentally healthy.
And so I would really recommend trying this.
Even you can try the program,
you don't have to do a perfect job at it.
It doesn't really matter because it turned to set out a bit of a vision and a
plan for your life.
And you need that because you need direction and you need purpose and you need
the constraints of a vision to help you be less anxious and uncertain.
And,
and you,
you have that anxiety and uncertainty reduction does occur if you have a decent
map of where it is that you're headed.
The coupon code is n y 2019 New Year's 2019 and why 2019 and if you go to the
self authoring site and click on the products menu,
uh,
item
and go to a future author and you could just enter in that coupon code and it's
50% off.
So I think the total price is $7 and 45 cents,
which is actually pretty damn cheap.
If what it does is help structure your future.
And I really do think this is a helpful,
we've worked on it a lot and tested a lot and it's based on solid behavioral
psychological principles,
Lli with,
I would say a certain degree of,
of optimistic philosophy and um,
it's,
well,
it's a good thing to do
and um,
this is a good time to do it.
So if you're interested,
all that information will be in the description of the video as well.